hi everybody happy Tuesday welcome to
the posit Enterprise Community Meetup
if you've just joined now feel free to
say hi through the chat window and maybe
where you're calling in from
also like to say if you want to connect
with each other in the chat that's all
for you too so feel free to use the chat
to meet other people who are joining us
today as well
special welcome to those joining us for
their first time today this is a
friendly and open Meetup environment for
teens to share use cases teach lessons
learned and just meet each other and ask
questions
these happen on Tuesdays at 12 eastern
time not every single Tuesday but we do
have a community event calendar which
I'll share in the chat in just a second
here you can also use the link shared on
the screen here too
together we're all dedicated to making
this space inclusive and open for
everybody under your experience injury
or background
during the event we'd love to hear what
questions you have as well so you're
able to ask questions on YouTube live
and also anonymously through slido
uh which I will share on the screen in
just a second here as well link and I'll
put it in the chat
to address one common question up front
yes the recording will be available and
it will actually be ready right away
like immediately as the presentation
ends at the same exact YouTube live link
at one of the recent data science
Hangouts which happen on Thursdays at
noon eastern time I was able to get a
little bit of a view into the amazing
work the team at Unity Health Toronto is
doing to bring predictive analysis to
different clinical problems and resource
problems in the hospital
and I'm so excited to be able to dive
into that deeper today with Chloe pupron
Chloe is a data scientist with the data
science and advanced analytics team at
Unity Health Toronto
their team uses high quality Healthcare
data in innovative ways to catalyze
communities of data users and decision
makers in making transformative changes
that improve patient outcomes and Health
Care System efficiency so love to bring
Chloe up here on stage with me our
virtual stage here thanks so much for
joining us Chloe
hey uh thank you for the introduction
Rachel and thank you all for joining
um I'm really excited to be talking
about tools and insights for developing
and the playing algorithms in the
hospital
um so actually as I was developing the
slides there were a few alternate titles
I had considered
um another one that I had considered was
this one right here uh which is how we
got our model out of one person's
computer and deployed it to the hospital
which I think is an app description of
the things I'll be talking about for the
next hour or so
um yeah so I guess um for uh the next
while um also another time going over uh
dsca who we are what we do uh where we
started versus where we are now and
really just diving into the main content
of the talk which is what are the things
that you need for a development
um and what are the things that you need
for deployment and all of this of course
is in the context of working in the
hospital working in the healthcare
setting
um yeah so hi everyone I'm Chloe and I'm
a data scientist for the dsaa team at
Unity Health Toronto
um so DSA or rather the data science and
advanced analytics um it's a healthcare
data analytics group at Unity Health
Toronto also known as uht
um throughout the slides there are a few
acronyms I'll try my best to expand them
I think acros might be like a data
science thing or maybe a hospital thing
and it was I'll try my best to expand
all of them
um yeah so basically yesterday's aim is
really to work with little work with our
collaborators and also our partners to
make better decisions increase Hospital
efficiency and improve patient care and
patient outcomes
um so in particular because we're
working in the hospital the projects
that we work on that will require
process and change management
um so that's how you work directly with
clinicians and with administrative
decision makers to develop and deploy
our Solutions
um now what kind of solutions do you
work on a little bit of a little bit of
everything so we have solutions that
will rely on statistics some of the
focused warrant and artificial
intelligence so machine learning some on
optimization like operations research
for example
currently we have more than 40 Active
Solutions at Unity Health Toronto and
these are for example solutions for
predicting patient outcomes for enhanced
clinical management
uh planning for hospital bed capacity we
have some Medical Imaging AI tools and
we also have some solutions for
assignment and scheduling
um here is an example of some of the
things that we've worked on so right
here I have a screenshot of our covet
dashboard
um so here what we're reporting are the
counts of people who are code with
positive people who have been exposed to
coven as well as people who previously
had covet and are now recovering
um and um in this case we're we're
showing accounts for the three different
uh sites uh that make up our Hospital
Network
um so Unity Health Toronto is based in
the greater Toronto area and um it is
made up of three different hospitals so
we're sharing the
um the numbers for those three hospitals
here we have an example of um our Wharf
dosing tool this is an application for
calculating the wharf and dose based on
various input features
um so Warfarin is a medication so it's a
blood thinner and um we're calculating
uh the dosing based off different input
features
and then we have our emergency
department forecasting tool
um so if you're counting the number of
um
patients are arriving to the Ed
um so on the right hand side you can see
we have our forecasted numbers and we're
also reporting the historical numbers so
you can get a sense of how well the
model is doing
foreign
so who are the people that work uh
within the data science and advanced
analytics group
um so our team is actually made up of
four different teams
so we have the data integration and
governance team so they are the ones who
will take the data and will
um you know
um connect to the database
um uh transform the data in a way that
is uh amenable for data science
and then we have the advanced analytics
team
um so there are the ones who are taking
the data and building a model on top of
it
unless we have the product development
team so they're the ones who are
deploying the model
um so they're also the ones that are
handling any kind of like Downstream
Integrations so for example if you have
a model that is supposed to send a push
notification the product development
team uh will be the ones who are taking
care of that
and finally we have the support team who
are really uh the glue to hold
everything together
um so they're the ones who take care of
project management management and
coordination are both an internal and
external level
um so because we are collaborating with
lots of different groups within hospital
um this is where we're having the
support team is really helpful
foreign
I briefly talked about some of the
different solutions that we worked on
um I want to kind of like dive in and
focus on one solution in particular
which is a successful deployment and
known as charge
um so in August 2020 we deployed chart
watch which is an early warning system
for detecting patient deterioration
um so it's been running since August
2020 and to this day it's still running
in the hospital
um chart watch was applied to the
General Internal Medicine award
um within the hospital
um I guess as an aside why is it called
chart watch
um really it's a it's a branding thing
so before becoming known as the SAA we
were actually known as chart which is a
standard for healthcare analytics
research and training
um so one thing you may notice uh
throughout the talk is like I do mention
a thing on this chart
um and it's really for uh because of who
we were initially known as
um so yeah so we developed chart watch
it's an early warning system and uh
really it's a model that predicts which
patients are at risk of deterioration
um so what I mean by deterioration is
any of the following so either transfer
to the Intensive Care Unit or the ice
you death in the hospital are
transferred to the palliative care unit
so the way that the chart watch model
was chained is it was chained on about
20 000 uh patient visits
um and these data consisted in
laboratory values vital measurements and
demographics so these are all things
that you would typically find in an
electronic health record
and the way the model works is it
outputs a risk group so for every
patient you would generate a risk group
so the patient will be classified as
either being high risk versus medium
risk versus low risk
and then these risk groups are then
delivered to different end users
and we have different methods of
delivery based on who the predictions
are going out to
so for example we have emails these are
then to our charge nurses our palliative
care team
and what these emails contain is
basically a list of patients with their
rescript listed uh so if you look at the
column the third column from the right
you'll see the the chart watch risk
groups are included here
um another uh method of delivery is
updates the front end tool
um so here we have a screenshot of our
electronic sign out tool which is
typically used by clinicians and if
you'll notice here the screenshot has a
column for chart wash so once again the
third column from the right you'll
notice there's a chart watch column and
this contains the chart watch risk
groups and in this case the risk groups
have been color coded so a high risk
group color coded is red low risk group
is green and the medium risk group as
yellow so we're following the traffic
light system in this case
and then finally the last method of
delivery is alerts that are sent to
phones
um so for patients that are flagged as
high risk we actually sent out an alert
to a clinician phone to let them know
that the patient is at a high risk of
deterioration
um so yeah so going through the
different methods of delivery
um really they're they're varying a
level of urgency uh based off the end
users that they're going to and based
off the information that's being
communicated
um and you can read more about it and
these links below um the slides will be
available to share and you'll be able to
access these links and also at the very
end I have
um I'll have slides with like all of the
links resources and papers that I share
throughout the talk
okay so uh I've got another chart watch
um but I have this slide just to really
pause take a step back and reflect on
how we got from where we were to where
we are now
so okay I should have probably titled
the slide back to the past because we
are going to the Past
um so just to give a bit of context
um this is where things were at before
so before we had scripts that are
running from one person's laptop
um it works but lots of ways in which
this can fail so you know what if this
person is sick what if they go on
vacation
um most of the laptops we use are
Windows laptops what if we get that uh
Windows updates you know like laptop
will be out for a while
um we have no logging we had no
development environments
that's how things are before
now where things are at now well you
know things are much better we have
service accounts so basically this
removes the Reliance on one person
um we love all the things we have
staging versus production environments
and so much more
so how do we get from before to now
it's a really it's a combination of hard
work trial and error lots of talking
talking to the right people figuring out
what works and also what doesn't work
um and I'd say out of all the tools and
findings I think we can summarize them
into two categories so we have the tools
for development and also the tools for
deployment so let's Dive Right In what
you need for development
so the first thing that we need for our
development is really connections to
databases
um So within the hospital there are
various Data Systems so for example we
have a different system for labs a
different one for surgical procedures
and so on
um so in order to help the data science
team work better we developed a package
called a chart DB so try TV is an
internal r package to interact with
Hospital databases
and um with regards to connecting to
databases we wrote a bunch of connection
functions and they all follow the same
pattern
so for example if I want to connect the
database a I just need to give us input
my username and my password if I want to
connect the database B I also give us
input my username and my password and if
I want to connect to the hospital's
Enterprise data warehouse rather the edw
I would give as you expect my username
and my password as input to the function
so internally this is actually what's
happening so internally I have a bunch
of retries because you know the
connection may not work the very first
time uh we also have a bunch of checks
so making sure that
um the connection is successful and that
what's being returned is uh what you
expect
so chart DP offers uh connection
functions and it also offers other
utility functions
uh so for example I have this get
patient ADT function right here and what
ADT stands for is admit discharge
transfer
um so basically when I call this
function it will return a list of uh
patient uh movement events so I have a
real fund the patient first gets
submitted to the hospital when they
transfer for example from the emergency
department to a medical award and then
when they get transferred and you know
knowing where a patient is located in
the hospital is pretty useful in nearly
all of our projects
all right so we have database
connections another thing that we need
for development is an environmentalists
multiple people Cloud project are really
uh reproducible development environment
so in order to help with that we ended
up using uh RNs um here I have a link to
our ends and here's a screenshot of the
documentation
um as I said before at the end all of
the links will be included
um in the slides
um so RN is an r package for our
dependency management
and how are we using our project well
here's an example of our project
structure so you know we have our main
folder we have a bunch of uh files a
bunch of subfolders and really I want to
bring attention to that last file at the
end which is the RNs unlock file which
is where
um all of the RS magic happens
so this is what the rn.log file looks
like and basically what it does it
specifies the different packages that
your project relies on as well as the
different package versions
um so for example here uh my project
relies on deeply ir and I'm using
version 1.0.7
um so you know I could then give this
im.lock file to a teammate uh and then
they can uh that intro they're
downloading the same packages as all the
same package versions so uh contribute
uh on the project
all right so we've highlighted a few
things for development so I have my
database connections I have
um my reproducible environment which is
facilitated through RNs another thing
that I need is functions and utilities
that you reuse so really what I mean by
that is package based development
so here I have a link to the r packages
text block as well as a screenshot of
um documentation highly recommend it
um it's really why write a package there
are a bunch of reasons but I said that
for us specifically what we found the
most relevant was being able to share
code and knowledge with others
um as well as having no more copy
pasting so I find that as I'm developing
if I'm copy pasting the same bit of code
over and over kind of like
you know it rings an alarm you're like
maybe I should take a step back and
think of what I'm doing
um so if we revisit the project
structure that I introduced a few slides
ago and this our subfolder right here is
where you have all of your uh package
functions
and then there is a description file
right here which is um where you would
Define the attributes of your package
uh so for example this is a description
file that I have for chart watch
um so you know it's listing out a bunch
of attributes like the package name
right here so it's chart watch uh the
package version
1.11.10 and at the very end I have uh
the Imports right here which specifies
uh the packages that my package relies
on so the dependencies
yeah
okay so our development uh checklist is
um we're adding more to it so you have
our database connections you have
environment there allows multiple people
to collaborate we have package based
development uh another thing I'm going
to add is environments environments
environments
so the reason I see the same word three
times is because we actually work with
three different environments we have the
development environment the staging
environment and the production
environment
so the development environment
um this could be your local computer uh
but in our cases we usually use a
development server
um so at our development server includes
is gpus which allow for you know any
projects that work hard deep learning
um and also the development server works
when I see with chart DB
um so that means that anyone who wants
to develop something you know they're
guaranteed that database connections
will work for them so they'll be able to
access uh the data that they need for
their projects
foreign
environment which is as close to the
real deployment environment as possible
so for example when we need to make
updates to chart watch we would first
apply to the staging environment to make
sure everything is working as we
expected
and then finally there's a production
environment which is where things
actually get deployed
all right so things I need for our
development the last thing I added was a
thing about environments
briefly talked about the production
environment which I think segues nicely
into the next point which is what do you
need for deployment
it's actually before I dive in I'm just
going to take a small intermission so I
can
reflect a bit on chart watches
deployment
so chart watch was applied on August
2020.
um but it's actually first silently
deployed in November 2019 and I guess
the reason for this large gap is because
um initially chart watch was supposed to
go live in early 2020 uh but then the
pandemic happened it affected plans
um the hospital's priorities shifted at
that point you know they wanted to focus
on containing
um
um the rising number of covet cases in
the hospital uh and then you know charge
kind of like took a bit of vaccine
so yeah it was first highly deployed in
November 2019 and this is actually here
a screenshot of what the uh chart watch
repository looked like back then in
November 2019 so the very first time we
tried to deploy it
um I guess a few interesting interesting
things that I want to highlight here
so first of all there are two folders
that start with zero zero interesting
oh
Chloe warned me that this might happen
don't worry they are testing it's not a
real fire
um
Chloe I mentioned I could fill the time
if that happened I'm not sure how long
the fire alarms will go off but
um I did just want to remind people that
you can ask questions if you're watching
on YouTube live
or you can also use the slido link which
I will
show on
the screen for us as well
I see that there's two questions over
there now so
I can read them out for you Chloe so
that they can be top of mind as well I
think you might be covering this in just
a second here but
uh one of the questions over there was
can you talk more about the development
process for this what came first were
there steps dependent or parallel or did
these changes happen simultaneously
and if the alarm's still going off no
worries we can cover it up later
okay it's still going up well
I will use
okay awesome I will use the time to also
just let you know
um I usually share this at the end of
the event but I saw somebody ask the
question about it as well so if you are
interested in figuring out
where to find upcoming events
um I created a this is actually a quarto
doc here that is published to our
connect instance but it has a nice
calendar where you can see everything
that's happening in the next few months
so the meetups that happen on Tuesdays
but also data science Hangouts that
happen every Thursday at noon Eastern
Time
and so this Thursday we have Eric Nance
joining us from Eli Lilly as our
featured leader for the week so at the
data science Hangouts I'm curious of
anybody listening in has been to one
maybe comment in the chat
um
but there's a different data science
leader that joins us every week and just
answers questions from you all so
maybe you have questions about
how they're thinking about hiring or how
they're structuring their team or about
different technologies that they use
there's no presentations at the Thursday
events it's all just kind of open
conversation among everybody and lots of
questions so definitely recommend
joining one of those too
and I see Libby says yay Eric yes I'm
really excited
for Eric to join us this Thursday as
well
how are we doing Chloe on the alarm
I think it should be okay okay if ever
become Sparkle go back on mute
um I saw it was a comment about like is
that smoke behind you
um no but it might be snow because it's
snowing outside so maybe that's what's
behind me
and I see I just mentioned the um the
community events and I showed the link
on the screen but I also just copied it
over to the chat if you want to um
check that out there too
but I will hand it back over to you
Chloe thanks thank you
uh all right where was that all right so
I mean it's funny if the alarm happened
during the pause story time period
um yeah so I think you are going over
um this is so yeah this is what the uh
repository structure looked like when
they first tried to deploy and I was
just pointing out a few interesting
things about that uh so just to recap
um there are two folders that start with
zero zero interesting
um at the very bottom there is that
error check.py file so you know there is
python code here
um and then also I have my DOT rproj
file at the very bottom so there is R
code
um and actually if you look at each of
these different subfolders you'll find
you know a mixture of r a mixture of
python I believe we also had some Java
code at that point
um
oh
sorry I thought I had the alarm
I think where I think we're at almost at
the end I think there's some saying that
it was still testing
okay
awesome
bear with us here just a few minutes
okay let's try
I think it should be over
I don't
I can't hear it from the background okay
10 seconds I think it should be okay
um
yeah I'll just continue and we'll see
what happens
um oh no I hear it again
okay let's see we could take a few more
questions from people too any questions
for me let's see this is really scary
but I can I can uh chat for a little bit
as well while we're waiting
how about any any ideas for for meetups
or things that you'd really like to
learn a little bit more about as well in
the future we're starting to think ahead
for 2023 so I would love to
hear from you all
feel free to put some suggestions into
the chat I also can go ahead and make a
poll over on slido right now too
uh I'm going to say any suggestions for
meetups in 20 30 23 what would you like
to learn
okay
I just launched that poll over on slido
oh yes Libby I think supply chain topic
would be great as well
yes thanks Rebecca we can all use a
pause sometime we can never everybody
can stretch get up get some water
oh Marlene that's a great suggestion too
how organizations are using new packages
I was also talking with a team
uh recently who was talking about like
creating their own company-wide tidy
verse packages so like or like in a
sense tidy verse but packages that are
important for their company and like
company branding too which was cool
any other Meetup suggestions
foreign
I know there was a ton of interest in
the people analytics topic from last
week too so I was just talking with a
few people
from the people analytics space about
some future events for that as well
oh and yeah it's Jake thank you yeah
suggestion on
packaging app content with Golem as well
yeah on the topic of incorporating
branding I see Marlene you just put it
into the chat I was curious if people do
have packages at their own
like your own internal packages that
include your company branding is that
something common
and feel free to put everything into the
chat just a reminder like the chat is
great for questions but also to like
share resources and links with each
other as well
Chloe how are we doing on the alarm
I think it should be good or else I said
that last time
um that let's see what happens okay so
I'll just try yelling see if you could
hear me over the alarm
yeah
so uh actually I just want to dress like
there are some really great great points
uh in the chat I really like what you
guys are saying about branding
um so that's kind of like one of the
things that we try to do with our uh you
like our chart DB package
um yeah definitely like that
um
so uh going back to how things were
before uh so let me first try to deploy
chart watch we had a mixture of python
and R scripts and also some Java and the
way we were running everything is we had
this complicated uh thing whoops let me
see if I can share
uh
sorry oh sorry there's a bit of lag in
my slides being updated
um yeah it says yeah the way things are
running is we had a mixture of python
our scripts and we have got this uh craw
job I was calling different baskets
which was then calling different Python
and R scripts
um
and then I guess where we were the
biggest red flag is that our test
environment was our staging environment
which was our production environment
so for example in chart watch one of our
outputs was
um an email which contained a list of
patients with their risk group and you
can imagine like as I'm developing this
I would send that email to my my uh my
email and you know make sure things look
as they should be but because our test
environment was our staging environment
was our production environment uh when
it came time to sign a leader Paul I
would have to like comment out the line
that had my email and then set it to be
you know whatever test email we had and
presumably when we would move to
production I would then comment out that
one line and set it to like the end
user's email
so you know like if if I'm very diligent
if I'm very careful things will work out
but this method is very prone to errors
so
with that being said
um oh are my slides not updating
me
oh yeah
um so without that being said what are
the things that you need for deployment
so the first thing that we really need
for deployment is authentication
um so all of our deployed applications
run on RC to connect
uh which is actually now posit connect
um so one of the nice things about posit
connect is that it interacts with the
hospital's active directory
um so what this means is that users can
authenticate using their Hospital
username and password so for the
developer you know we don't need to keep
track of an extra server username and
password and then for the end users in
order to access applications they could
just log in with their Hospital
credentials
and a nice thing about
um being able to interact with active
directory is that we can just use the
existing groups to manage permissions uh
so for example if I have an application
that I only want to give access to uh
the SAA so like the data science group I
could just use the existing Active
Directory Group to enable that
uh another thing that rco connect rather
positive connect allows us to do is to
schedule Scripts
um so we run our applications from
service accounts uh which is basically a
non-user account
um in which we can run automated
services and it's this combination of
automatic scheduling and using a service
accounts that uh really makes us that
deployments don't rely on one person
so you know this is how things were
before we had this uh Cron job which
would call different batch scripts which
would then call different python R
scripts uh but now that we're using
um our not using positive connect
um
you know there's a we can leverage a lot
of different things
um sorry the the screenshot is a bit
small so I listed all the different
things all the different tabs on the
side
um so you know we have the application
information we have the access tab which
is what we use to specify uh for example
who can access a specific dashboard
um we have to runtime settings we have
the scheduling settings
um so scheduling settings is what we use
to schedule our scripts and then there's
uh the tags really for organizational
purposes so for example all the chart
watch scripts would get tagged as being
chart watch environment variables and
logs
okay so we're adding a few things for
deployment we have authentication we
have scheduling another thing that's
useful for deployment is being able to
know when there's a downtime
so for example here this is a screenshot
of one of our slack channels where you
know we received an alert
um you know chart watch is down for
example
um so in order to enable this uh we
created Jarvis which is an art package
for helping us monitor our production
applications
um so Jarvis is um the
uh Iron Man's uh robot assistant
um yeah that's that's where the
packaging came from
um yeah so we use Jarvis for uh a few uh
notifications so we can use it to send
email alerts so in this example here you
know Jarvis and email letting me know
that there's an issue with the covet
dashboard
um as shown previously we can use Jarvis
to send slack messages so like here
and we also use Jarvis to check the
health of systems that we depend on
um so for example if you want to check a
specific database right I can check that
uh my connection to the Enterprise data
warehouse still works
um and I can also check that I can
access different file systems like
Jarvis
uh so on top of uh using Jarvis for the
different notifications we also
developed a few downtime protocols which
are pretty Project Specific
um so for example with chart watch if
ever there's something that goes down uh
we would send
um this kind of email to the hospital to
all the hospital users
um so we have the specific email
template that we use here
um and this email template actually
follows the one that it uses
um so you know it's color coded at the
top where you know red is for unplanned
downtime blues for plan down time and so
on
um there's a list of things that we need
to specify and this will go out to uh
all the hospital users
um so like not all projects will require
something like this uh but something
like chart watch which is embed into
clinical care does require something
um a bit more robust
um basically like when when things go
down with chart watch it's just it's not
just the dsaa team that needs to be
notified it's other people within the
hospital
right so you have authentication
scheduling down time
um I'd say another thing that you need
for the deployment is
um a secure way to download internally
developed packages
um I think I need to expand on this
event more
so
um see a bit of context around the
holiday time last year
um we started seeing these kinds of
messages in our slack channels so you
know like not able to receive emails you
know check log4j
um sorry running late because I was on a
meeting with it because of log 4J
um you know if you use pie charm be
careful there's a log4j file in there
you know I found log project files in my
vs code folder
so there's something going on this Vlog
for Jay uh it's a long 4J for this don't
know it's a Java based logging utility
and in December 2021 there was the log
4J flaw and basically what happened is
this could allow malicious users to
access internal Networks
and I guess just to highlight uh the
severity of the log 4J flaw like here
are some headlines that were coming out
around that time so log4j is a pervasive
vulnerability update your devices now a
whole and a popular piece of code is an
open window for criminals
um the log 4G software flaw is endemic
according to the Cyber safety panel
so really this this whole thing about
log4j is to motivate the next point
is that you know we need to limit who
can access the hospital Network and this
is where something like positive package
manager comes in uh so pause the package
manager awesome following our studio
package manager is a repository
management server and what it allows us
to do is download packages while being
disconnected from the internet
so if I go back to uh RNs which I
mentioned a few slides ago
um remember we had our rm.log file which
specifies the different packages and
versions
um so here uh it specifies how the
package is being downloaded so instead
of being downloaded from say GitHub or
from cran
um or downloading from rspm which stands
for rco package manager which is also a
positive package manager
um yeah so a few more things that we've
added for deployment so we just added a
secure way to download internally
developed packages
um one more thing I want to add is an
implementation plan
so so far all the things that we've
discussed previously
um I guess you can apply to data science
in general uh for this implementation
plan it's a probably a bit more focus on
the healthcare setting and on uh
deploying within the hospital
so just to recap uh how chart watches of
the delivering predictions um they're
going to different end users so we offer
emails that are going to charge nurses
the palliative care team uh we're
updating this electronic sign out
front-end tool that clinicians access
um or sending alerts uh whenever there's
a patient that's five that's higher risk
this is going directly to clinician
phones
and really if you like just looking at
the the way things are
um delivered there's a lot of people
involved so you have like your charge
nurses your palliative cream you have
I.T
um you have residents and Physicians
and it's with that in mind that when we
uh um when we came up with uh what when
we put together the implementation team
we wanted to make sure that uh people
from all these different end user groups
are being represented and included in
these implementation team meetings right
so we made sure we had people from
General Internal Medicine from the
Intensive Care Unit from palliative care
from Clinical informatics from it and
then like from the data science team
um just on the Highlight that like
collaboration is really important here
um and also the whole idea for chart
watch actually came from a general
internal medicine doctor uh so they
don't they were the ones that are
leading the project uh throughout the
whole course and really making sure
um we were going from development all
the way to deployment
um so one of the things that the
implementation team was tasked with
doing was uh coming up with an
intervention so after chart watch Flags
a patient as being a higher risk what
happens then
so the implementation team developed a
clinical workflow
um this is a clinical workflow looks
like I won't go into too much detail but
I will point out a few things
um so you know when the patient is
flagged as being high risk by chart
watch there are a few things that need
to happen after that so one of them is
you know placing orders to increase
Vital sign measurements
um reviewing recent Labs reviewing
recent medications and recent Imaging
orders and really all the things that
you find in this clinical workflow are
all things that a clinician would
normally do if they suspected a patient
of deteriorating
um so I'm developing this uh this
checklist this clinical workflow it was
really important to make sure that it
wasn't disrupting any existing processes
um so yeah so you want to consider
existing resources you don't want to
re-implement a workflow that already
exists for example
um and also the alerting notifications
all fit within existing processes so for
example when it came to the timing of
emails uh some of the emails that we
sent out is sent to the charge nurse and
this email is sent out twice a day and
they're sent on a time that makes the
most sense with how the shifts work so
once again we don't want to disrupt uh
how things are working currently
uh and you know with regards to the
clinical pathway
um really ensuring that there are time
targets so for example after chart watch
Flags a patient that's being high risk
uh one of the things that the clinicians
must do is uh increase the number of
vital measurements within 24 hours of
the alert being said so having this
24-hour time Target makes it that we can
then go into the electronic health
record and then measure the whether or
not this is happening
and of course leaving room for clinical
judgment
um so so when working on the
implementation plan uh we included a
sign deployment period uh so basically
this is where your entire pipeline is
running but the the file outputs are
silenced
um this is useful for identifying bugs
and addressing unexpected changes
such as change to how the troponin uh
lab test is done so the Japan test is
one that's commonly used to diagnose
heart attacks and other heart related
problems
um so during the deployment of
um chart watch
um like the way this was measured got
changed is something that we had to
address so we had to address that in our
data extraction code and also in our
data processing code
other changes that can happen can be due
to the applying at the beginning of the
pandemic so you know during that time
there's lots of rooms that are being
made available or unavailable based off
you know the patients that are testing
positive for covid uh patients are being
moved to completely different units in
the hospital just based on capacity so
this has to be addressed in our data
extraction code
another thing that the sign the planned
period was useful for was after catching
bugs
um so this is a really interesting bug
that we encountered
um I'm guessing that most people that
are watching this talk are our users
um so you know I can ask the following
question how are missing values
represented in r
so I think most of you know um it's in
our missing values are represented uh as
M.A which means not available
so the chemical element for sodium is
also an a
so we work in the hospital in the
hospital there are blood tests that are
done
um and you know one of the things I get
measured in blood test is sodium
so when we silently deploy chart watch
we noticed that there were no sodium
tests that were being measured
um just an example uh this is a graph
that shows kind of like all the
electrolyte counts
um so in blue Estonia and if you notice
here the blue is set to zero I'm like
okay like this doesn't seem right like
what's going on so when you went and
checked the code what we found was that
uh the r code that we were using to Read
sample Labs data was interpreting all of
the sodium tests as being n a not
available
foreign
period
um it's time to go live
um so actually for us we had a pilot
phase in which we uh first deployed to
two General Internal Medicine teams only
um and during that time we had weekly
meetings which were used to you know
debug any issues we ran into uh go over
the patients that were flagged by
chartwatch and you know check like does
it make sense or is there anything weird
or unexpected
um so that was the approach that we took
uh for uh going live we really didn't uh
a phase approach so start off with two
teams then deploy to the rest of the
teams
and really throughout this whole process
so throughout the pilot phase threat
signed the climate throughout you know
developing the clinical workflow uh end
user engagement is important um this is
not something that could have been
possible with just a data science team
um when it came to developing the
clinical pathway we really relied on you
know the G the General Internal Medicine
team on the palliative care team
um the nurses we were working with to
develop that pathway I also when it came
to developing Education and Training
processes that was once again a highly
collaborative effort
foreign
implementation plan super important
um one last thing that will that I will
mention for deployment is uh something
about monitoring
um there's a question mark here because
you know this could be a whole talk and
we're already nearing the end of this
talk
uh so we it is the whole talk there's
plenty of other people that are spoken
about monitoring
um so I would redirect you to watch
these amazing talks um lots of great
insights
um with the time remaining I will
mention a few things specific to char
watch though
um so with chart watch one of the things
that we want to look at is model
performance
um
but that's a bit hard to do once the
model has been deployed
let me expand on that a bit more
somehow we got kicked out there but here
you are am I still here it was just for
a second yep okay
all good yeah we're good okay
um let me just backtrack a pic so
um with chart watch one of the things
that we want to look at is model
performance
um but that is difficult to do once the
model has been deployed
um so clinicians one of the things that
they asked for was a Target positive
predictive value of 0.33
so what this means is that for every
three alarms at least one of them should
be correct
uh but that is kind of hard to measure
once you are deployed in production so
what I mean by that is let's say chart
watch Flags a patient as being higher
risk and sends out an alarm
and then that patient doesn't
deteriorate like they don't transfer to
the ICU they don't die
um does that mean that the chart watch
prediction was incorrect
or does that mean that the charge
prediction was correct and then because
clinicians receive that alert they were
able to intervene and prevent that
outcome from happening
so yeah in deployment we we get into
these cases where there are these uh
false alarms which we're not sure if
they're actually false alarms or if
they're averted outcomes just based off
this uh successful intervention
um yes uh another thing that we Merit in
chart watch is the daily number of
alerts
um so on average we're sending two
alerts per day which is a reasonable
number that the clinicians are happy
with
um there are some days where there are
no alerts and there are some days where
there are lots of alerts so for example
I think there's like nine or eight
alerts uh sometime uh in like April or
May
um so yeah one of the things that uh we
were really uh concerned with was I'm
sure there weren't too many alerts so we
worked with the clinicians to ensure
that we were minimizing alerts
so right now the way things work is that
you know a patient will receive an alert
if chartwatch classifies them as being
high risk
uh we added some additional rules on top
of that and those rules we developed
with the help of the end users
so you know we don't really Allure
patients unless it's been 48 hours since
their previous alert and you know this
just ensure that we're not alerting for
the same patient every hour for example
um and we added this additional rule
which is that we don't alert a patient
if they just came from the Intensive
Care Unit
um because if a patient is coming from
the ICU you know like the clinicians
already know that they may not be doing
too well and it's expected that you know
their vital measurements their Labs
might be might be looking a little off
because they just came from uh intensive
care
um the last thing I will say about
monitoring is regarding clinical
adherence
um so how do we know that when a patient
receives a chart watch alert um the
clinician is actually doing something
and they're not just ignoring that alert
um some of the things that we look at is
number of vitals that are measured after
an alert is sent
um so we do that because
um as part of the clinical workflow one
of the things that the clinicians have
to do when they receive a chart watch
alert is increase the number of vital
measurements
as this is something that we can easily
measure just by looking at the
electronic Healthcare record
um looking at the number of vitals are
sent after an alert has been sent
um I mean it's um it's not a perfect
measure because the number of vitals can
then increase for reasons unrelated to
chart watch uh but it's a proxy uh and
it gives us a good enough idea of a
clinical adherence
um so this brings us towards the end of
our talk um so let me just summarize
some of the things that we talked about
um so we looked at the different tools
for development and employment of an
early warning system in a hospital and
sauna development side the things that
we found useful were you know database
connections reproducible environment
facilitated uh through RNs package-based
development
um the the different development stages
production environments and then on the
deployment side we had authentication
and scheduling which were facilitated by
posit connect uh we had downtime
protocols a secure way to download
internally developed package packages
with the help of positive package
manager we had an implementation plan in
which we're working with our different
collaborators our end users and then we
had a monitoring at the very end and you
know all of this uh would not have been
possible if it weren't for collaboration
I think it's something I keep saying
throughout the talks that collaboration
is really important
um developing and deploying chart
watching the hospital is not something
that we could have done on our own that
was really by working with
um a great team and a lot of different
people within the hospital that this was
possible
um so this brings us to the end of our
uh what I prepared
um and as I said before the slides will
be available and at the end I do have a
list of all the papers uh talks blogs
that I mentioned you can all find them
at the end
awesome thank you so much Chloe I really
love the the storytelling through the
slides too and all the the images
those are awesome
there are a lot of questions that are
coming through
um both on slido and through the chat so
I just want to remind people you can ask
in the YouTube chat
um as well as the slider link which I'll
just put on the screen again here in a
second
there we go awesome so Chloe I'd love to
just dive into some of the these
questions if if that's okay with you I
I'll jump over to slido and see some of
the most upvoted ones too
one from the the beginning which we
touched on
for a second is
can you talk more about the development
process what came first were there steps
dependent or parallel or did these
changes happen simultaneously
um a lot of things were happening at the
same time so uh in the talk I think I
mostly focus on the implementation team
and like all the things that the
implementation team was doing to get
this from development to deployment uh
but there were different sub teams are
working on this so there was the uh
evaluation team which was you know they
were trying to address the question like
how do we ensure that the chart watch
deployment is successful so they're the
ones that are coming up with like uh you
know we should measure vitals because
you've got to measure clinical adherence
in one way or another and there was the
modeling team which is you know mostly
the data science people and some of it
that are focused on actually building
the model
um
so different teams working all at once
um I'd say the way this all started was
really from uh the general internal
medicine doctor who came up with the
idea first and you know came to the DSA
team and said like hey like it would be
cool if we had an early warning system
and it's kind of like all snowballed
into this
thank you
you see somebody else asking I guess
this is a follow-up year but did the the
team come first or did you architect
these workflows and then build the team
um so like the the DSA team or rather at
that time you were the chart team like
we did have the chart team first so we
didn't have a data science team I'd say
like the the different groups like The
implementation team is something that
came as we uh progressed as we started
uh working towards uh
um developing the tool
so we had all of the the building blocks
first assembling it together that kind
happened a bit later
so on the topic of the team building
then can you speak to any Lessons
Learned From building four teams within
dsaa what did it take for leadership or
management to take on a big skill
project like chart watch
yeah that's a great question so when we
first started off we did not have the
14th structure it was we just had data
scientists to do a bit of everything
um but we found that you know there were
certain people who were a lot more
knowledgeable in one aspect
um so I think it just made sense to
split it up into this four different
teams
um and then with like within each of the
teams there is a a director for each of
these teams I think it makes it a lot uh
like it makes the the management and
coordination a lot more streamlined all
right so as a data scientist I can focus
on doing data science work I don't need
to think about like you know all the
other unrelated things
absolutely and I see Rebecca asked a
question over on YouTube what is going
on under the hood for those alerts that
you showed us
um
Rebecca just mentioned like how do you
begin with either like functions for
emailing or database status
yeah yeah so I guess more specifically
when we're checking when we're checking
the database that's we are just checking
that uh connection can be made
um so you know I just try to connect
using my usual connection function if
that doesn't work then I know that
something's going on uh with regards to
actually sending out the alerts for
sending slack alerts um we are working
with a slack API to send that and then
for sending out emails
um this is something you can do uh
um there's a bunch of our packages for
that actually so the one we use is send
mail R uh this is what we use to send
out our emails
I was gonna go try and capture the the
link to put in the chat but
it's hard to do both those
um I see Ezra also asked over on YouTube
how early in a project do you typically
shift to developing in our package
oh that's a good question that's
something that we sometimes struggle
with um because I guess you don't want
to do it too early because it might seem
like you're kind of like over
engineering things
um so I'd say for us specifically is for
chart watch it was
um
uh like so we first deployed in November
20 we first finally deployed November
2019 and everything was put on pause and
it was over the summer that we decided
like okay let's just fill this all as an
r package so I'd say by that time like
we had all of the requirements kind of
like all nailed and we all knew like you
know this is what the a learning schema
would look like this is what these these
were the different groups that we would
be like uh interacting with
um started to like wait until you know
what the final requirements would look
like before shifting to developing in
our package
foreign
thank you
um I see toyan just asked how long did
implementation planning take large
stakeholder groups can be unwieldy
yeah
um
so the the idea for chart watch I
believe it initially uh
like the the idea initially started like
back in 2018
um and yeah like large singular groups
can be unwieldy it's lots of uh schedule
managing and you know trying to find a
time that works for everyone
um but I mean I think that's one of the
things that we want to make clear is
like if you want this to actually be the
point implemented you need to be
committed to working towards like you
need to be able to show up to like you
know our monthly meetings our bi-weekly
meetings
um
so yeah it was it was hard but we we
managed to get it working I think it was
a lot of credit goes to the support team
who was able to make all of these uh
meetings happen and I'm sure that's you
know like the project coordination
um actually I followed through with that
thank you I noticed that was a common
question too like somebody had outside
asked that as well so thank you
um jumping back over
to fly actually somebody asked this so I
think over on LinkedIn how does dsaa fit
into the overall organizational
structure
so we are directly part of the hospital
um
so
um
yeah like I guess let me start off we
were a bit more research-based but then
um
I think it was in 2019 or 2020 we
officially became part of the hospital
so you know like Advanced analytics is a
priority for the hospital
thank you I know a little bit ago you
were mentioning like the idea for a
chart watch came from
uh one of the clinicians and
trying to find the question that I
copied over here but I can I can read it
first oh here it is Mark asked in what
way are clinicians involved in the
development process how do you
prioritize what you work on as a team
yeah so clinicians are completely
involved they're involved from day one
um our our project intake model is very
clinician-driven so it's it's not that
the SDA group that comes up with the
ideas It's The End user that comes to us
with an idea and then we work together
so in this case we had Dr amol Verma who
came to us so like hey I want to develop
an early warning system let's work
together into doing that
um so yeah collisions are involved from
day one
I'm throwing a ton of questions that you
hear if you need to take a sip of water
okay keep them coming okay
um another question was how did you
succeed in gaining the confidence of
decision makers in the application
uh I think for this is
um
also we we leverage
um the the clinicians we're working with
so a mole was really useful in you know
talking to uh the clinicians and you
know telling them like hey like it's a
chart watch model is something that is
reliable that works
um I think that also the education piece
was useful in Education and Training so
it was useful in uh getting the
different end users accustomed and used
to chart watch
um
and also when we first deployed um we
did have regular meetings so it's a good
way to kind of get like a like a Vibe
check make sure like hey like how are
things going like are people still like
receptive to that I was just checking in
regularly and ensuring that you know
everyone was happy with how things are
going
awesome I see another question and I
might need help with an acronym here how
do you deal with the medical device
regulation
um if applications for example chart
watch fall under the category of samd
yeah uh yeah
um so I believe Charles doesn't actually
count as a medical device so the way
that we deploy this was all under the
umbrella of quality improvement
um because I know that when we react
right if you like uh
if you went through a bunch of
documentation that I always found their
quality improvement uh yeah that is a
really good question
thank you um a question I had and let me
just double check there are other
questions that
I missed
oh and thank you Mark for clarifying in
the chat samd equals software as a
medical device thanks
a question that I had is if somebody
maybe Works in a hospital today and is
inspired by the talk that you gave and
is thinking like I want to get started
and I want to do this at our hospitals
is there any advice that
maybe wasn't mentioned in the
presentation that you would give people
for getting started or what you wish you
knew
ahead of time
good question
um reach out to other people that are
doing this in the field so I think let's
talk to other groups and figure out like
what work but also what didn't work was
really good for us because we know like
okay like this didn't work let's not
explore that
um
like talk to the end users right talk to
the doctors and nurses what are things
that they like what are things that they
don't like what are things that they
want
um because at the end of the day they
are the ones who are going to be using
this tool
um so you don't want to you don't want
to waste your time building something
that no one will use right so it's
really talking to your end users
um will be really useful to a successful
deployment
thank you very much I see there was a
question earlier I had missed around
python support and I was curious if
your team is using this tool with both R
and python I think you mentioned a few
python users too yeah so when we first
our very first deployment was a mixture
of python R and uh Java
um when we read the play we ended up
actually cutting it down to
we went to extreme lighter but so the
um the latest version of uh chart watch
is actually only our based
yeah but yeah our team is has a mixture
of python and our users
I want to double check from the chat
that there aren't questions that
I have missed but just a follow-up from
my question Chloe
um about like what you would have wished
you knew and you said reach out to other
people how did you go through that that
process of like identifying who else you
should reach out to or other teams so
you can learn what they did before
uh so I think I I think I'm very lucky
in that
um
uh muhammadani was kind of the VP who
was uh who led the project from
beginning to end he's very well
connected uh so he knew a lot of people
he had a lot of people on like one on
the application side but also on the
research side
um so he was able to reach out to them
and set up these meetings that's how we
were able to
um have all these these discussions that
really helped to uh kind of like where
we are now
yeah so let's see I really just reach
out to your network
um yeah
I always like to say this too and
sometimes I forget but if you do want to
connect with people and you're listening
and on the chat if you want to share
your LinkedIn oh I realize I shared it
from the posit account instead of my own
but
um if you want to share your LinkedIn to
connect with each other I know there's a
lot of people here listening in who are
doing similar things as well so I'd love
to just use the opportunity to be able
to help connect people as well if you're
looking to get started and
you don't know who to reach out to feel
free to connect with me too and I can
try and connect you with others in in
the space as well
let me just double check once more I
think we
have gone through all the questions
thank you so much Chloe for an amazing
presentation really really appreciate
your time and answering all these
questions if people do want to get in
touch with you is the best way LinkedIn
or
yeah um feel free to add me on LinkedIn
um specify that you're from the talk uh
always love to meet people that you know
have an interest in healthcare and data
science
um also I I think in the slides that I
link to uh our team website and also our
team blog um so feel free to check that
out there's some cool things that we
write about there
that's great thank you all so much for
joining us and as I mentioned in the
beginning the recording will be
available at the same YouTube live link
but I'm also going to go in right now
and add time stamps from the Q a and
then some of the helpful resources that
Chloe mentioned too I'll put in the
details with the recording thank you all
so much for joining thank you Chloe have
a great rest of the day
thank you bye everybody bye